All right, let's do this.
It's time for all things drama.
Kevin.
All right, let's get into it.
Drama series nominees.
And let's start with "Bridgerton," "The Mandalorian,"
"Lovecraft Country, "Handmaid's Tale," "This Is Us,"
"Pose," "The Crown," and "The Boys."
Now, in my opinion, and this is Kevin Frazier speaking,
it is a two horse race and it comes down
to "The Crown" versus "Pose"
because here's the thing, "The Crown" has never won,
but everyone loves the Lady Diana story.
And that's why I think "The Crown" will win.
Excuse me though, but can we talk about "Bridgerton?"
We could talk about Bridgerton.
Where are our veils?
Drew and I were obsessed with this show,
and we were not alone.
Ross and I rode that "Bridgerton" horse
until it literally told us, get off, we're tired.
I got saddle burn.
(Ross laughs)
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
I love it.
What do you say?
And it was worth it.
It was so worth it.
And you know, this is tough for me.
I'd like to turn to our followers and see what they predict.
I hope they give "Handmaid's Tale" some love.
I know, right?
"This Is Us."
Wow.
I'm glad to see that broadcast television
is reigning supreme because we're all
on broadcast television.
Right, we need y'all to come through.
I believe that means we can keep our jobs.
All right, Ross, your turn.
All right, let's move on to lead actress
in a drama series.
I always love this category.
And here are the nominees, Nischelle?
Oh, my girl Uzo Aduba
nominated for "In Treatment."
We also have Olivia Coleman for "The Crown."
Of course, yes, she plays the queen, Emma Corin.
Elizabeth Moss for "The Handmaid's Tale."
MJ Rodriguez for "Pose,"
and our friend Jurnee Smollett for "Lovecraft Country."
You know, I can't call it for this one.
I'm serious, guys.
I think that this could be anybody's.
I do think that, you know, Emma and Olivia
are gonna battle for this.
They could cancel each other out.
They absolutely, and that's why I think MJ Rodriguez
has a really, really strong chance.
It would be so deserved, but it would also be so historic.
Yeah, absolutely.
A trans person up there accepting that award
with say so much.
And the performance earned it.
That's what I was gonna say.
The performance earned it.
I don't think it's easy to predict this one,
but let's look at the results of our social poll.
Oh boy.
Oh!
Wow!
Elizabeth Moss in a runaway.
Come on, Elizabeth Moss.
In a runaway.
Let's go.
Let's go, June.
Now I'm a little shocked 'cause she has one for the show.
Yeah, she has one, but we'll see.
We'll see.
All right, finally, lead actor in a drama series.
Here are the nominees, Kevin.
All right, let's run it down for you,
and let's start with Sterling K. Brown
from "This Is us."
Jonathan Majors from "Lovecraft Country."
Josh O'Connor.
Rege-Jean Page.
And this will be probably the only time
he's nominated for "Bridgerton" because we know he's left.
Why you gotta bring that up
in this show?
I'm just saying.
Why you gotta do that?
We've all been calling him for fun.
Billy Porter, Billy Porter Jr for 'Pose."
And don't count him out.
That's what I'm saying.
Like we look at all these other names,
but boy, he was so good.
And then of course, Matthew Rhys for "Perry Mason."
Well, here is who our followers voted for.
Tally it up. Let's see.
Sterling K. Brown.
Sterling.
(audience claps)
And that's a overwhelming Sterling K. Brown.
41 %.
And he has won before.
He has.
Yes, he has.
(upbeat fun music)